Andrew Warren, Author: I always feel like you
should start writing when you feel you're not
quite ready. I think that's the time to start
because I think if you keep researching and
researching and researching you're holding off on
the real work because that's not the real work.
Film Courage: How do you keep an underlying
sense of danger and tension in every scene?
Andrew: I think a lot of that is part of the
setting. Understanding the location lets you
describe it in a mysterious, dangerous way. I
think if you have a feeling for the location
where is it, a seedy area, is it a high
crime area, is it a rich wealthy area? What
things are either likely to happen to you there
or what might be surprising to happen to you there
depending on the direction you want the scene
to go. But I think for me a lot of that comes
down to knowing the location and really getting a
feel for it. I know that might sound weird because
it's not directly related but that's usually what
I go to first. It's like what is the mood of this
area?Then how can I sort of color that mood
to be a little bit more dangerous? Let's say
someone how would you say that this character
Thomas Caine is a chameleon in some sense,
he can really blend in. How is he operating
when walking through a bad part of town, whereas
he's walking through a business center where
there's professionals with nice leather shoes.
Most of the stories actually tend to take place
in more seedier locations so I think he's probably
more at home in more dangerous areas like I mean
he there have been er usually if he's in an area
that's more upscale he just acts like a tourist
he acts like a clueless tourist because he knows
that's the most likely scenario for why someone
like him might be there but I don't know in
terms of making the audience feel like something
can happen I feel like you sort of need to have
a sense of the locale there's a the book three
that's set in Sudan that's a war-torn region and
so I really tried to play up the the condition of
the buildings and there's armed soldiers walking
around everywhere and everyone's on edge and you
see like smoke rising from a building somewhere
because it was bombed the previous day like
those kinds of details I think are what make
the reader start to think like oh wow
anything could happen here like who knows like
so I think I to me it comes down to the location
and and communicating that to the reader it's
interesting that you said that he would pretend
he was a tourist and I had heard that from a
journalist on a panel she said that when she would
go into certain war-torn countries she would very
much put on like a touristy garb and because
she was less of a threat right and and so people
overlooked her yeah which is very interesting yeah
I mean if you're if you're a white guy walking
around china like they're really only a few things
that are plausible and why you would be there so
I see so so he has a camera and and I know he
doesn't go that far with it but he just sort of
that just tends to be the rationale or he just
pretends he might he might pretend he doesn't
understand the language even if he does or he
might ask for in one scene he asks someone for
directions right before he attacks them because
he's just trying to play off that he's like a
lost tourist things like that we imagine
there's many many times you've put Thomas Caine
in some impossible position where it
seemed like he wasn't going to get out
is there an example that you can use where you
backed yourself into a corner and how did you
get out of it so you're writing and you're like
wait a minute how am I getting out of this scene
I don't have a plan for it sure actually in
the very first book the climax takes place on a
thing called Tokyo Skytree actually when I
started writing it took place on something
called Tokyo tower but in the years that it took
to finish the book Tokyo tower became no longer
the tallest structure in Japan that when I started
it was when I finished it was this thing called
Tokyo Skytree so I moved it because I thought it
would be more exciting to be the tallest building
in Japan so Tokyo Skytree is this big big tower
I think it's about a half a mile tall with like
a little observation deck at the top and I knew I
wanted to have a scene with Caine fighting people
at the top of this tower and there's like a drone
zooming around them and all this stuff going on
for the outline that's about as much detail as I
would do but when I started writing it I was like
well okay at some point he's gonna be hanging
off the tower and then what like what do I do
like obviously he can't fall but how do I make it
interesting that he doesn't fall like what does
he do is just pull himself back up or like what
makes the bad guy go away or like and so I was
sort of stuck I wasn't really sure what to do but
it for me the answer just came down to research
I just kept researching it was really hard to
find accurate blueprints or pictures of the tower
I don't know why but so I just had to keep at
it most things when I research I can usually
find what I'm looking for pretty quickly but
for whatever reason it just I just had a hard
time finding detailed enough pictures where
I could sort of plot out the scene in my head
finally I found this video of people
washing the windows at the top of the tower
and they have these little carts that like lower
down and then move along on tracks and I was like
that's it and so in the scene I had him spot one
of these carts that's like hanging half up and
he like is able to swing himself into the cart
and then he has to like climb the wire and jump
onto there's this big like glass tube that wraps
around the top of the tower where it's like an
up where you can look 360 from this observation
deck so we had to like jump onto this tube and
fight the guy on top of this glass tube like way
above the city and so the research just just not
giving up on the research is really what allowed
me to finish that scene in a satisfying way
if you can't find what you're looking for with
the research at what point do you move on do
you give yourself a time limit or is that
part of the fun I mean I certainly wouldn't
I wouldn't stay on it for forever I mean I do
think you have to keep things moving and so if
you're not finding what you need I think you I
at some point you either change the scene like
you go back or you just come up with something
else I mean I think really it all comes down
to what's satisfying for you right because that
scene I just described I'm sure you could give
that to 10 other writers and they'd come up with
10 other ways to make that interesting there's all
kinds of things you could do but nothing was
clicking for me so I think at a certain point
if you don't find the answer then yeah you
either need to just try a different tact
or maybe go back okay well maybe he doesn't fall
off maybe he throws the guy off and then realizes
the guy has something he needs and he has to
get him back or I don't know you just try to
find what would be interesting and work from there
I do think actually I think a lot of people over
research and I love research and it's important
but I think that a lot of people use research
as an excuse to not get started and I think
that that's a danger actually I always try to
I always feel like you should start writing when
right when you feel you're not quite ready I think
that's the time to start because I think if you
keep researching and researching and researching
you're just you're holding off on the real work
because that's not the real work and also I’ve
found that I i think you'd be surprised what you
can get away with because if there's something
you don't know you just don't point the metaphoric
or the literal camera at it I mean the novella
took place in Thailand and I needed a scene by
a river and I was driving myself crazy trying to
find like where would a river be in this region
and I couldn't find anything and finally I just
said why am I going through all this trouble
I just said yeah I just cut I just started
the new chapter and he's by a river I don't say
exactly where it is no one has ever like said well
where could there be a river in this province of
Thailand if you only had this many out I think
that people overdo it on that stuff so I do what
you need to get yourself invested and interested
and I think you can do a lot as you go from
that point on the internet's always there
do you limit yourself though do you turn like the
wi-fi on it's not a no it's not like a literal
time I just have a sense now from having done
it like you're you're putting it off now you're
putting it off it's like you're putting off
the work you're researching too much you got
to just get going I just have a sense in my head
of when it's time to start writing but do you turn
off your email and different text messages not
really sometimes every now and then I will but
most of the time I'm able to just ignore it you
know I’ll put my phone in the other room maybe.
When is the perfect time to start writing?